and joining us from pittsburgh to
discuss the issues in more detail is dr
amish adelga a senior scholar at the
johns hopkins center for health security
at the bloomberg school of public health
dr adelga let's start there
so much hope with the new year with the
vaccine but this rollout seems so slow
right
now why there's multiple reasons that
that are holding up these vaccines
turning into vaccinations
one is is that delivered doses isn't the
same thing as an administered dose and
when states get these
doses there is a process before they get
them to their
hospitals get them to their nursing
homes and they have to figure out to
make sure that the priority is right
that the right health care workers are
getting it
and there's a a staffing issue because
you have to remember that many of these
hospitals are dealing with the same
patients
with covet that they now need to get
pull staff from and then
create vaccination programs and that's
not easy to do and the other thing is is
that states sometimes have
unpredictability of when the doses are
going to arrive sometimes doses may
arrive late
sometimes they may arrive ahead of
schedule that's why there needs to be
federal coordination federal leadership
because
this can't this hodgepodge network
really can't really deliver vaccine
vaccines at the pace that we need to put
this pandemic behind us
doctor some are predicting that tomorrow
is going to be the busiest
travel day since the pandemic began
hospitals already being pushed to
capacity i know you're heading
to the hospital right after this
interview how concerned are you right
now about january
i'm very concerned we know that there
has been a surge of cases starting out
even before thanksgiving then then
augmented by thanksgiving and christmas
and new year so we're going to continue
to see
cases rise we're already at record
hospitalizations
and hospitals really can't in a
sustainable manner go through day-to-day
worrying about supplies staffing icu
beds
that all is going to push hospitals
closer to the breaking point or crisis
standards of care where they can't
do their other operations we already
have hospitals that have started to stop
non-emergency surgeries
this type of approach isn't going to
work we've got to get some
handle on the number of cases and the
number of hospitalizations and to do
that i think we have to get the vaccine
accelerated
because that's really what's going to
give us breathing room in the hospitals
but
that's going to take some time so i do
think january is going to be one of the
more deadly months that we've seen
in this pandemic doctor on top of that
you also have this new variant that we
know is in at least three states how
concerned are you about that and how do
you think that that changes
the sort of containment strategies
the new variant it appears has the
ability to transmit more efficiently
that's what the laboratory studies are
showing
that's what the statistical modeling is
showing so that means that we have to
double down on what we're doing we have
to be better at washing our hands
wearing face coverings avoiding crowded
congregated places
and and that really also adds more
urgency to the vaccination program
because we have to stay ahead of this
virus that's constantly going to be
evolving it doesn't change anything
specifically that we do in tactics it
just means we've got to do it better
because if this virus strain starts to
take hold
you will start to see an acceleration of
transmission the way they saw in the
united kingdom and
you can't really allow that to happen in
this type of an atmosphere in the united
states where we have uncontrolled spread
in many communities around the world
around the country you mentioned the uk
and in the uk they've decided to delay
giving that second dose in order to
vaccinate more people with the first
it's been something that's been
discussed here where do you stand with
that
this is a hard decision to make because
we know that there is some protection
that's given after the first dose
but all of the data is based on a
two-dose regimen so that's where we're
most confident that the vaccine
will work the uk made a decision based
on their their own standards
i don't necessarily think it's the same
decision the united states can make it
was good to discuss it
but i do think that the two-dose regimen
is the surest way
to do this but you know i think things
may change depending upon
what the dynamics are and what data we
get on just what a one-dosed
regimen would do okay dr amishadalja
thank you very much as always